تفش لكورونا منذ بداية الجائحة.
بينما يستمر الحجر الذي كان قد
التاسعة والاربعين دفاع جوي في
الجيش الروسي العقيد ايفان
كييف يزيد مخاوف السكان في
العاصمة الاوكرانية. القوات
الروسية ويحد من تقدمها في
المناطق الاخرى تجدد القصف على
المحتجز لدى سلطات كييف يطالب
اوكرانيا بمبادلته مع سكان
العقوبات وقال انها ادت الى
تدهور الاقتصاد في الغرب وفي
الحلفاء الامريكيين. الذين
انشأوا شبكة من ثلاثين مختبرا
مؤخرا لكييف بالقرب من مدينة
الفيت. اجتماع في الامم المتحدة
للشعب الروسي بان روسيا تحقق
اهدافها وتحرز تقدما في ميادين
الدول الخمس دائمة العضوية في
مجلس الامن بتبرير استخدامها لحق
التي يقطنها خمسة وعشرون مليون
نسمة. ماذا بعد يا اصحاب العيون
العمال الكردستاني شمال العراق.
مدينة شنجهاي تواجه اسوأ موجة
قطاع غزة. فهل تشتعل المعارك بعد
هذه الضربات? اتصال بين امير
للفصائل الفلسطينية في والمقاومة
ترد بصاروخ ارض جو تجاه
الساحل الاوكراني على البحر
الاسود ما يمكنهم من قطع نشاط
ماريبول سيكونون بذلك قد سيطروا
على اكثر من ثمانين في المائة من
ومصيرية مع روسيا جعلته يقول
ذلك. لماذا ماريوبول. يستميت
بيترو اندريو شينكو. القوات
الروسية تواصل قصف مصنع بكل
مليار دولار من مجموعة الدول
السبع الصناعية الكبرى لتغطية
التعاون مع روسية. اوكرانيا تعلن
مقتل ستة مدنيين في قصف روسي
واعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي ان القبة
الحديدية تصدت لقذيفة صاروخية من
المحتلة والتصعيد في المسجد
تركيا توجه ضربات عسكرية لحزب
تم على المواطنين في المدينة
اواخر مارس الماضي في المدينة
دولة قطر والعاهل الاردني لبحث
مستجدات الاوضاع في فلسطين
عن انفسنا. بعدما كان الرئيس
الاوكراني قد حذر سابقا من ان
كبطل حتما وانما كانسان عادي. بل
سيدخل زينسكي معركة كبيرة
مطلبه من عائلته وشعبه في حال
مات خلال الحرب انه يريد منه من
ومدافعي مدينة الاوكران. الدفاع
استمرار حصار يقيد القوات
تحتجزه السلطات الاوكرانية.
بينما المعارض الثري الاوكراني
الالماني كان ينسق عن كثب عمله
في مجال الامن البيولوجي مع
الطائرات. وبعدها ساد هدوء حذر
في غزة عقب الغارات الاسرائيلية.
بينما اعلنت وكالة الانباء
الاوكرانية عن قائد الفرقة
للامم المتحدة بطلب من لمناقشة
مشروع قرار دعمته واشنطن يلزم
النقض. المتحدثة باسم الخارجية
الروسية ماريا زاخاروفا الجانب
الروح المعنوية فالنصر في
ماريبول سيسمح للكرملين بالاثبات
الاسود. وتعد ماريبول اكبر
الموانئ في منطقة بحر ازوف. رفع
عدد الجنود الروس الذين تم
احضارهم الى هنا. سنقاتل وسندافع
معركة السيطرة على الدومبس التي
كانت تستعد لها منذ وقت طويل قسم
اندريه دينيسوف السفير الروسي في
الصين بهذا التأكيد فهل تنضم
انواع الاسلحة. قال مسؤولون روس
ان نائب قائد اللواء الثامن
استهدف حيا سكنيا في البيبي
الاوكراني. مستشار عمدة ماري بول
المدنيين. القوات الروسية تكثف
هجماتها الصاروخية على مدينة
الاوكرانية تقصف الحدود الروسية
وموسكو تتهم كييف باستهداف
امكانية لذلك؟ هجوم روسي. قال
الرئيس الاوكراني فولوديمرز
الدولي. وجاء في البيان ان نائب
وزير الخارجية الصيني ابلغ
زيادة التعاون الاستراتيجي معها
بصرف النظر عن تقلبات الوضع
محتجزان لدى القوات الروسية
يطالبان كييف بمبادلتهما بسياسي
حديثه عنه الاقتصاد الروسي قال
بوتين ان التضخم يستقر وان الطلب
على بضائع التجزئة في البلاد قد
عاد الى طبيعته. بريطانيان
اوكرانيا التجاري البحري. خنق
الاقتصاد الاوكراني فلطالما كانت
لمناقشة نص يقيد استخدام الفيتو
حيث يجتمع اعضاء الجمعية العامة
بواسطة صواريخ عالية الدقة مخزنا
للاسلحة الاجنبية التي سلمت
كبير جدا من الجيش الروسي مكرس
حاليا لهذا الهجوم. بغض النظر عن
الروس للسيطرة على مدينة
ماريوبول لعدة اسباب اهمها تأمين
الصين الى روسيا ويقرر الغرب
وامريكا معاقبتهما معا هل هناك
وزارة الخارجية الصينية في بيان
لها ان الصين ابلغت روسيا انها
ستواصل زيادة التعاون
الاستراتيجي مع روسيا. وقالت
ايام. بكين وموسكو. اعلن مسؤول
صيني رفيع المستوى ان بكين
خامسة خلال اربع وعشرين ساعة ما
يعني خمس رحلات في غضون بضعة
ماريبول ميناء استراتيجيا مهما
بحر ازوف المفتوح على البحر
ممر بري بين القرم والدومبس واذا
نجح الروس في السيطرة على
يتذكرونه كما احب الحياة الى
اقصى حد وحبه لعائلته ووطنه ليس
وامريكا وبريطانيا ترسلان دعما
لاوكرانيا وتعدان بالمزيد وسط
ترقب للوضع في مدينة ماريبول امل
اوكراني بزيارة للرئيس الامريكي
الضيقة? هل ستعيدون الجائحة
للعالم? مرة اخرى. تعاون روسي
جميعا افقر مما نحن عليه. طلبت
اوكرانيا دعما ماليا بقيمة خمسين
عجز الميزانية بفعل الحرب
الروسية. قصف اسرائيلي على مواقع
جريشن. وزير المالية الالماني
يقول الحرب في اوكرانيا ستجعلنا
ارسلنا شحنات اسلحة الى اوكرانيا
تتضمن مدافع هاوزر وسنرسل
ديلينسكي في كلمة يمكننا ان نؤكد
الان ان القوات الروسية بدأت
وتبون ايضا الوضع في اوكرانيا.
تعزيزات امريكية. البنتاجون
الولايات المتحدة محملة بمعدات
مختلفة ومن المتوقع ان تصل رحلة
واضاف الكرملين ان الزعيمين
اتفقا ايضا على مواصلة التعاون
المزيد. وقالت التقارير بوصول
اربع رحلات جوية الى المنطقة من
للجيش الجنرال فلاديمير فرولوف
قتل في المعارك في اوكرانيا.
خركيف. زالينسكي يطالب
الاوكرانيين بالصمود وعدم
الالمانية بوتين. الدول الغربية
اضرت بنفسها عندما فرضت علينا
بيولوجيا على الاقل في اوكرانيا.
بانتظار رد رسمي من الحكومة
في منتدى الدول المصدرة للغاز
بما يخدم الحفاظ على الاستقرار
التي تضم كبار منتجي النفط
ومواصلة التعاون بين البلدين.
المدينة؟ موسكو تتهم برلين بصنع
الاسلحة البيولوجية في كييف
الروس يريدون من دومبس وتدميرها.
الامنية الاخيرة. زالنسكي يوجه
القتال. الاحداث والتطورات.
الجيش الروسي يؤكد انه دمر
بخصوص اوكرانيا. صواريخ المقاومة
تتوجه نحو تل ابيب ليسود الاجواء
في اسواق الطاقة العالمية. وبحسب
الكريملين ايضا فقد ناقش بوتين
لزيارة اوكرانيا زينينسكي يريد
رفع رح مقاتليه المعنوية بزيارة
اوكرانيا وفق ما اعلن البيت
الابيض عقب اعلان كييف ان روسيا
بدأت بشن هجوم جديد للسيطرة على
منطقة دومبس الشرقية. الجزائر
رئيس اقوى دولة في العالم
ولاثبات صمود الاوكرانيين في
وروسيا. الكريملين الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين والرئيس الجزائري
عبدالمجيد تبون يتفقان على زيادة
التنسيق في اطار مجموعة اوبك بلس
اجتماع مع حلفاء الولايات
المتحدة لبحث تطورات الوضع في
وبكين تعلن عن كارثة انسانية في
الصين؟ زينسكي يضع مطلبه الاخير
وامريكا ترسل اسلحة حديثة
لاوكرانيا وتتعهد بالمزيد. الصين
دعوة اوكرانية. الرئيس الاوكراني
يوجه دعوة للرئيس الامريكي
الدفاع عن ارضهم في حين يعتزم
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن عقد
من عائلته؟ وبسبب روسيا اجتماع
يقيد نقض الفيتو قرارات الاممية.
تلبية هذه الدعوة؟ اجتماعات
روسية جزائرية تقلق الغرب
تعلن تعاونها صراحة مع روسيا
وبايدن يدعو حلفاءه لاجتماع عاجل
بعدها هدوء حذر فهل هو الهدوء
الذي يسبق العاصفة؟ لماذا تستميت
الى اوكرانيا لرفع معنويات الجيش
والمواطنين. فهل يحدث ذلك قريبا?
زيلانسكي يدعو الرئيس الامريكي
الى اوكرانيا هل يجرؤ بايدن على
القوات الروسية للسيطرة على
مدينة ماريبول؟ وما اهمية هذه